yeah how's go I'm Foofa I'm Tony riddle
and I'm known as the natural life
stylist looking at the natural world and
natural peoples of the world to find
ways of living that are more in sync
with our biology and I took rich Troost
and biologically normal ways of running
or at least normal ways of running with
an appropriate posture for running so we
were rewilding running and I would start
and stuff just really so this is amazing
look here well that I can do we try this
[Music]
so you won't running hands like this and
we go from this hop to this hop to this
hop to this hop there's no rhythm and a
cadence to run it so we run between 176
and 180 beats per minute if you're
jogging is more like this
which like 163 beats per minute you work
with the forces kinetics again which of
the external influences and then you
have kinematics which are the shapes you
make due to the courses if you get the
cadence right means you use the
appropriate muscle and tendon actions
which makes you super soft so if you're
on a really hard surface like this who
gives you or the hard surface we did
right so that's the harder the surface
the better the discipline for us really
because it enables us to really tune
into those actions but only if we start
to tune in to the appropriate timing
sameer shaped otherwise what ends up
happening is those forces creep in you
were probably too much muscle action and
the tendons don't understand they're
elastic role so say 80% of runners give
up to injury knee injury low back to
necks its impact forces again and it's
just being able to deal with the forces
right over there how we display them
throughout the body so we're gonna work
with um by this we're gonna go one two
three four so rather than here put this
one down I just pull this one up and the
other one will just let it go
I'm not thinking about putting my feet
down I'm only thinking about pulling my
feet up all right I've gotta wear this
out the old tighten it's right in here
huh so rather than driving your knee up
I want you to think about pulling your
hamstring up so hamstrings a huge
pulling muscles like a bicep the SCOOTER
bicep for more website so we're gonna
pull with it
[Music]
so we gonna go ding ding dings really
explosive hamstring only thinks rich
about pulling nothing else I know ain't
pulling drill but not as high but it's
the same tempo so you could be like this
you're striking but when you get to here
is the only time you can change the pool
before getting to the next hill strike
so going back to your tell Romero runner
they're literally going from this pose
to this pose this pose all the rest of
stuff where the injuries are so you
think of the thing I noticed with
watching them run is how light on the
feet they are and it doesn't look like
there's any exertion and the cadence the
stride length is very narrow yep
so you think of it this way if I need to
go in that direction how do I get it do
I do I push myself over there or do just
fall right oh wow allowing yourself
reberty as if gravity's there boom I
fooled and then I just simply pull my
feet from the floor and I'm still
falling and all I'm doing is trying to
catch support underneath me gradually
how do you how do you square that with
like making sure that you're okay this
is the key so we think that we'd fall
from here right but if I fall from here
it means I'm falling backwards so what I
do is I allow from the head to my hip
that's one strong body line so like a
really strong posture and I'm almost
leading from my I say lead with a
heartbeat followed but if I allow my
ribcage to lean this way
the lien is actually coming from the hip
past the ball of the foot so I'm falling
now and what I need to do is maintain
this shape and just keep pulling my feet
Wow what's interesting about that is how
similar that is to swimming and what
people don't understand about swimming
which is that force is generated from
here pushing down and making the water
work for you and then you especially a
butterfly when you're trying to undulate
so you're you're you're generating all
the power of the force from here to here
and from here to here not in your legs
or your arms in your lives like getting
the water to work for you yeah and then
the hand plays a role in just changing
support mm-hmm so you catch weight in
your hand and then you're almost pulling
your body weight on the top of your hand
yeah I do the same thing with you let me
try that so just think it's super light
so don't think about falling is the
worst thing is to start thinking oh I've
got a fall from here because the whole
shape will go all you need to do is lift
your chest keep your head up and just
keep your feet underneath you so again
pulling really softly then I'm fooling
pop oh oh
[Music]
don't really think about landing flat as
opposed to yeah more so there's loads of
information out there around barefoot
running the people being taught to run
on the balls of their feet
yeah so when you walk you have three
rocking actions you have a heel rocker
an ankle rocker and then a fourth of
rocker the three actions and there's one
time to body weight when you're walking
so we missed a knee now it's one times
weight yeah in ground reaction forces so
when I run there's two times my weight
and then I spin this three times I like
this
nature's design is incredible so we have
like one rocker two rocker three rocker
in walking running to rocket free rock
going in sprinting three rocker so if
you're sprinting I want to be up and I'm
really falling just the angle of fall is
much greater in fact one on the balls of
my feet I'm going to slow it's rather
like this side man here and I put my
heel down then I come back up again it
doesn't make sense yes it's like two
three a rocking action and the key is
not to even think about landing so just
by getting those movement disciplines
back in it was like wow there's a
missing ingredient here boom and then
what's their foot shape okay so then we
can look at foot shape posture posture
comes in the environment and then all
the other categories that are in there
being a natural bit so it's just there's
a biological normal we're running the
same as there's a biological normal way
of moving it elsewhere it's balancing
lifting throwing defendant jumping and
then you can start to put those
applications everywhere the biologic
normal way of sleeping rest
even poopy you know it's all there and
then there's a social and spiritual
aspect of that too but all that came
from running with incredible wild man
all right let's go ahead let's go ahead
to trial
yeah let's do it
[Music]
so what do we do six or seven six point
six six point six I gotta tell you
there's a lot of rocks back there it was
crazy I you just danced over those
barefoot didn't even cut your feet at
all no I can't seem to impact you
looking great I would think there would
be super calluses but it's not Calais
they're like jelly pads almost again I'm
not I'm not trying to land on anything
I'm always thinking I've got to get off
things
so enter in it in that playful state so
instead of odd is a folder I want to go
over the boulder but pull over the
boulder the boulders I get like I can
wrap my head around that but it's the
little rocks like all the little sharp
little rocks that you yeah and on some
of those down hills we were hacking it
right now guys like ganas de San Cesar I
think like a big tractor wheel and I
have one foot at the top of the tractor
wheel and one for the bottom and I've
got to keep exchanging them as quickly
as I can and then my role is just to
keep the appropriate posture above it
you're planning on running from correct
me if I'm wrong from the South of
England to the north of England
something like 31 consecutive marathons
it's 13 miles a day 3 miles a day for 30
consecutive days lands in the southern
tip to the northern tip which is John
Brown and I'm basing and interviewing
sustainability experts along the road so
they come and meet me today and we we do
a little bit of the run together and
then we get behind the mics and then I
continue on my run I think if people
come out and join you absolutely so
there be a route up and anyone can join
the run and then we run and we pick up
litter along the route which means if
somebody wants to learn more about that
adventure in my Instagram at the natural
life stylist or my website tony
little.com
there's the sale
go do a podcast did it lead up to my
expectation - its kind of amazing times
great that gets you break up in the
round as well before that we've had like
an entire day experience
[Music]
you